On the political stage, he can be magnetic.
Much like he is when performing his music
for fans.
But Bobi Wine says his entertainment career
is being curtailed.
"I just wonder why the police continue to
persecute me.
More than fifteen of my concerts have been
cancelled.
The promoters of my music have been told to
stop working with me so that they can be allowed
to work."
On December 15th, Bobi Wine tweeted that police
had attempted to block him from performing
a show in the town of Jinja.
He managed to escape arrest and later gave
his account of what happened to DW:
“It was 8 O’clock in the night when the
Police raided the hotel when the army started
beating and arresting people.
Some kind people helped me to elude them and
I disappeared from that place and they looked
for me the entire night but they could not
see me"
Bobi Wine believes the police don't want him
performing his music shows as he is using
them as an opportunity to make political statements.
When the government was asked to respond to
the claims, Uganda's security minister answered
in parliament.
“I asked him (Bobi Wine) a question, how
will you balance your music with politics?
I will say that these are occupational hazards."
Bobi Wine won a seat in the Ugandan parliament
in 2017.
This followed more than 15 successful years
as a musician, a career he has refused to
give up.
"I am going to continue singing my music and
I am going to continue organizing my concerts.
When the Police continuously blocks me from
practicing my profession, from feeding my
family, they are continuously exposing themselves"
In August, Bobi Wine was arrested at a political
rally and reportedly tortured.
He was later charged with treason.
Bobi Wine has been a fierce critic of President
Yoweri Museveni, who's been in power for more
than 30 years.